The Curious Tale of Turnspit Dogs
Considering how most dogs in the Western world
these days are treated as a member of the
family, it’s often easy to forget that the
vast majority of our furry friends up until
very recently were bred for a specific purpose.
Perhaps no dog was bred for a more specific
purpose than the now extinct, turnspit.
The turnspit was so named because it was literally
bred just to run for hours on a tiny wheel
that turned a spit.
No, really, that was all it did.
You see, a few hundred years ago the generally
preferred method for cooking a large piece
of meat evenly was to put it on a spit and
rotate it until it was fully cooked.
Cooking meat thoroughly on a spit takes anywhere
between 40 and 80 minutes per kilo depending
on which meat it is you’re cooking.
Needless to say, roasting an adult hog on
the fire for a party took an incredibly long
time.
Prior to the introduction of turnspits around
the 16th century, the painstakingly tedious
and unrelenting job of turning the spit was
left to the lowest ranking member of the household,
“usually a small boy“, though in larger
households the size of the spit necessitated
delegating the job to an adult.
The job was tough, cruel and often resulted
in the poor soul tasked with doing it suffering
from burns, blisters and exhaustion.
What made the job more difficult was that
the spitjacks, as they were known, had to
work in full uniform.
In fact, during Tudor times, spitjacks working
in Hampton Court were told that they had to
stop working in the nude as well as to stop
urinating in the fireplace.
While we’d like to say that spitjacks were
replaced by dogs out of concern for their
health, the truth is that dogs could work
longer hours without a break and they didn’t
need to be paid in anything other than food.
This is why in 16th century, spitjacks were
phased out in favour of a small machine powered
by an even smaller dog.
So were the dogs treated any better than the
spitjacks?
Nope.
Turnspits were generally seen more as kitchen
tools than fuzzy members of the household
who needed just as many belly rubs and chin
scratches as normal dogs.
Along with being subjected to the same long
hours and awful conditions as the human spitjacks
before them, turnspits would often be cruelly
mistreated by their owners.
For instance, to train them to run at the
correct speed, a common method was simply
to throw a hot coal into the dog’s wheel
every time it slowed too much.
During their off-time, the exhausted turnspits
were known to work great as footwarmers.
Turnspits were ultimately replaced by steam-powered
machines and by the end of the 19th century
the breed officially was declared extinct.
Intriguingly, it appears that people from
the early 19th century were well aware that
the turnspit breed wasn’t going to last.
For example, in the book, Memoirs of British
Quadrupeds, published in 1809, in regards
to the turnspit the author wrote “It is
now on the decline; and, in the course of
another century it will probably be extinct
in Great Britain“, which mirrors the breed’s
actual fate almost perfectly.
Despite the fact that, for a few centuries,
the turnspit could be found in almost every
large home in England, including the homes
of royalty, nobody anywhere bothered to note
down exactly what breeding process went into
creating the dog that had ensured so many
people had evenly cooked dinners.
All we have to go on are historical descriptions
of the breed which described it as “long-bodied”,
“crooked-legged” and “ugly”.
We also have a single stuffed specimen called
Whiskey.
It’s not all bad though; the horrific treatment
turnspits were subjected to is reportedly
what inspired Henry Bergh to start the American
Society for the Prevention of Cruelty to Animals,
which in turn has resulted in countless animals
being saved from abuse
and cruelty.